do you plan on going back to tour
anytime soon or are you just gonna stay
uh I'm getting ready to put out the
special I just saw the last cut congrats
congrats thanks and um
yeah I'll probably
I don't know I'll probably put it out
and then get back to it right away I
already got some new oh great well
listen before you go on tour again you
know since I have all this extra free
time yeah no unemployed came up with
some great marketing strategies for my
next tour for your next one oh I gotta
see this uh just uh can we pull up the
presentation there we go
Noel's next tour strategy stay home
don't go don't go all right slide number
two here's the data uh and this is all
again data that we've uh sent out to
researchers sent with AI this is the
data of you listening to me and all the
success you'll be having right what's
going on so if I listen to you 25 in
terms it takes 25 of your advice I have
success that yeah that's how data works
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh all right
next slide let's see marketing ideas all
right your Flyers are too boring okay
okay they're too traditional bunch of
dates but yeah whatever a picture of you
doing stand up whatever yeah how about
you do those stripper Flyers ah local
Noel's laughs licker and ladies yeah
pretty good right with special guest
Walid oh I just that's a that's
tentative that's totally tentative that
was just uh get your tickets to
wallmillerlive.com we love Walid
interesting that's a good they use a
code uh and they get got it got a free
drink okay yeah all right a free laugh
to answer okay yeah theme chose
imagine if you did your show at a
Chili's not you know [__] huge
stadiums and theaters and [__] like that
right Mount Rushmore yeah Statue of
Liberty right whatever that military
installation yeah yeah yeah yeah right
the San Francisco bridge
mm-hmm
oh [__] the Golden State Bridge
was it called Golden State I think so
okay yeah Golden State Bridge Golden
Gate Bridge Golden Gate Bridge [__]
uh and again uh keep all your questions
towards the end uh okay the presentation
all right next next slide yeah uh
underrated marketing strategies now you
got to think about places you're not
hitting you're hitting Instagram Tick
Tock your site whatever this is your
show think about myspace yep it's still
around Vine
you missed you missed the boat on
pushing yeah last live show I'm still on
it I still have the app wow okay yeah I
saw that can you upload a Vine right now
oh
[Laughter]
give it a shot it's like Flappy Bird you
can't uninstall it all right yeah yeah
okay yeah Craigslist all right you'll
just get a bigger fan base and think
about this buy the crypto Arena you know
last time I checked it's not that
expensive how much is it it's like a
couple thousand
couple thousands
a couple thousand Millions yeah yeah you
buy the Kryptonite Arena we call it the
Noel Miller and Walid Muhammad arena for
goats right well see then the people
from Orange County you're gonna see
Wally Muhammad Arena
they're [__] coats
uh all right next slide uh remember when
YouTube forced everybody to another uh
album on the iPhone 4 smart Comedy album
onto the new Apple video that's what I'm
talking about now imagine giving them an
immersive experience right when they put
the headset on they like put it on
they're like it's just this yeah
this is my special and they're like
I only had I think one of the road
workers
uploading something upload something to
the Apple vision
uh Noel Fest remember fire Festival
right yeah now imagine you took
everybody out on an island for a
three-day on the well Comedy Festival
all right sounds like hell
camping accommodations
influencers
right and have everyone here on a
three-day weekend where you use
performers stand up non-stop imagine all
the new bits you come up with over there
yeah three days of straight yep all
right next slide
uh
try out okay yo mama jokes what happened
to those remember your mama fighting
yeah
yeah remember they used to like go do
recon at people's houses yeah actually
just remember that you remember that
yeah the MTV show yeah go to your house
and like oh look at this photo he has
I'm gonna use it you know what's really
funny was there was a rumor that they
were casting for people on that show
uh where I grew up and so like the rumor
evolved to a point where a bunch of
people showed up expecting camera crew
and [__] there was nothing there yeah
but I think everyone knew but everyone
just went because it was funny did they
did they do a Yo Mama fight or no I
think a couple of kids like tried to but
everyone's like yeah
um interrupting cow I forgot what that
was again uh political commentary right
people wanna you don't do enough of that
in your set dude yeah here's what's
really good
about Afghan people
yeah woke comedy
right so when you're like your eyes are
open uh no when you uh when you don't
joke about the liberal scum
I don't know much about woke people yes
uh black people versus white people be
like oh yeah you're right in the middle
yeah then it just seems racist yeah
after your YouTube videos live yeah
people would like that yeah just play it
up on the screen just be watching it for
an hour celebrity endorsements right you
gotta get you got all these cool friends
yeah you gotta get them to vouch for you
you know Pete yeah Pete I actually have
a uh dude I was actually talking to Pete
last night oh here we go I swear to God
I was talking to him last night let me
see hang on
jeez a lot of dick pics yeah
I'm like Tech talk dude this [__] was
crazy what's that yeah I mean I thought
he stole a joke of mine because he
started talking about [__]
it was pretty sick yeah dude yeah
yeah this is Pete Davidson
go ahead shout out Pete man
that's femass my dog man yeah clearly
I always want to know who that is it's
uh it's a
it is actually my friend
[Laughter]
um all right what else jokes
um oh here's an idea for an opener who
the [__] is that
it's uh
you'll see a resemblance
oh yeah it's me man those are the Orange
County goggles right there I was pretty
good yeah this is what I actually look
like walking around Orange County yeah
um
it says WTF where's the feet nice
oh
so any uh oh that's the end of the Q
yeah there you go questions I liked
everything how do we get rid of the
opener uh well have you you gotta try it
at least I used to do stand up yeah okay
well you said you still if I like my
success is right one it's a one to one
right so if I only listen to 95 of this
right technically that's still like yeah
but wouldn't you want to go for the full
100 but you know I'm fine with 95. okay
fair enough fair enough